mark zuckerberg wants to build the
metaverse but the crypto community has a
different plan now they might not agree
on exactly which crypto project is best
but one thing is for sure they don't
think zuckerberg stands a chance against
decentralization these crypto folks are
sick and tired of having one person
exercise absolute control and they're
funding independent projects left and
right that aim to unseat zuckerberg but
there's a big problem even though
trillions of dollars have poured into
cryptocurrencies zuck and the other big
tech companies aren't going down without
a fight facebook apple microsoft and
google are used by billions of people
and they aren't just gonna turn over the
keys to the kingdom to a bunch of
anonymous hackers with pixelated profile
pictures it's a knock down drag out
fight and in order to understand who's
likely to prevail we need to investigate
three important technological
developments
crypto will clearly play some sort of
role in the metaverse so let's dig into
the battle for payments between mark
zuckerberg and the crypto community it's
easy to write off zuckerberg as a minor
player in the crypto world but he's
extremely well connected after all one
of his longest standing board members is
mark andreessen whose venture capital
firm runs a multi-billion dollar crypto
fund that fund has invested in crypto
exchanges like coinbase nft marketplaces
like openc and even new blockchains like
solana so zuckerberg is clearly well
aware of the growing importance of
crypto but a few years ago he ran into a
big problem it was becoming abundantly
clear that crypto was going to be an
important technology going forward but
facebook didn't really have any way to
tap into that world billions of people
used facebook whatsapp and instagram to
communicate with each other but when it
came to sending each other money they
usually had to go to another service
like paypal or cash app so zuckerberg
saw an opportunity to change this the
idea was simple he would launch a new
cryptocurrency and then integrate it
directly into facebook this new project
would be called libra which isn't quite
as catchy as zuckerbox but there was a
lot at stake so i get why they wanted to
use a more professional name the first
question that came up immediately was
why not just use bitcoin tens of
millions of people were already using
bitcoin but the network was too slow for
zuckerberg's vision bitcoin could only
handle around seven transactions per
second but libra would scale to
thousands of transactions per second
sounds good in theory but when you're
dealing with crypto everything is about
trade-offs bitcoin has attracted so many
devotees precisely because there is no
need to trust anyone you can verify the
entire blockchain yourself if you like
but this comes at the cost of efficiency
of transactions at the opposite end of
this spectrum would be a coin completely
controlled by facebook you'd have to
trust them absolutely but they could
just store all of the transactions in a
centralized database and maximize
transaction speed now zuckerberg and his
team realized early on that this would
be a non-starter people were having a
hard enough time trusting facebook with
pictures of their cats so giving
zuckerberg complete control over their
money would be a stretch to say the
least so the libra team came up with a
compromise they would build something
that sat halfway between the fully
decentralized bitcoin blockchain and a
centralized database like visa this
distributed ledger structure would allow
libra to be the best of both worlds at
least in theory instead of facebook
having total control over the network 28
separate organizations would work
together to validate transactions these
validators were all big companies like
paypal and mastercard and they each put
up 10 million dollars and promised to
provide computing power on an ongoing
basis this had a big drawback though
instead of allowing users to see the
entire history of transactions libra
would only expose the current state of
the ledger this would make it faster but
you'd have to trust these big companies
and the crypto community had plenty of
other options fans of bitcoin weren't
likely to adopt libra anytime soon as
long as big companies were involved that
wasn't even the biggest issue though
plenty of people have no problem
trusting large corporations with their
money and data in fact most people don't
even think about it so telling people
that libra is semi-decentralized isn't
that big of a selling point see anytime
a new technology comes along there are
switching costs people naturally develop
habits and getting them to ditch
whatever they're used to in favor of
something new is never easy when credit
cards first came along they were
basically just competing with cash and
checks switching to a credit card meant
that if someone stole your wallet you
could quickly disable the card and
return any lost funds that was a huge
upgrade from cash so people switched
over in droves but now credit cards are
good enough for most people in order for
libra to become massively successful it
couldn't just be ten percent better than
credit cards it needed to be a hundred
percent better so zuckerberg and the
libra team devised a plan of attack
being faster than bitcoin was a good
start but it wasn't enough price
fluctuations had always been a natural
part of cryptocurrency and while most
day traders actually loved this feature
for your average consumer it would cause
major problems what if you go to buy
your groceries with libra and the value
collapses while you're standing in the
checkout line the solution was backing
libra with a basket of more traditional
and more stable currencies the price
still might fluctuate but it should be a
lot more stable than bitcoin this
created a new problem though and this
would ultimately lead to the early
demise of libra see the united states
government was already starting to take
a hard look at the platform that
zuckerberg had built over the last
decade more and more regulators were
arguing that facebook had too much
control over social media if the libra
project worked as planned that control
would now expand to the financial sector
and could potentially undermine the
monetary sovereignty of the united
states zuckerberg knew that he had to
tread lightly here the spotlight was on
him and ruffling feathers in washington
could have disastrous consequences he
announced that he would not launch the
currency until he had full approval from
the government but the challenge was
just too much to overcome so they shut
the project down
now while all this craziness was
happening with the libra project the
rest of the crypto world was absolutely
exploding billions of dollars flowed
into crypto projects and the top
developers started laying some really
powerful foundations the term metaverse
wasn't even in widespread use yet and
most crypto devs probably weren't even
thinking about mark zuckerberg but these
new blockchain technologies would wind
up growing into zuck's biggest challenge
yet it's important to recognize that the
term metaverse doesn't just refer to a
single game or vr experience we're
talking about the next phase of the
internet here just like mobile phones
wound up changing everyday activities
and creating entirely new opportunities
the metaverse is basically just a
catch-all term for the next phase of the
internet in fact the term metaverse has
been so completely co-opted by zuck that
a large portion of the crypto community
has moved to calling this whole idea
just web3 but regardless of what term we
use to describe it clearly payments are
going to play an important role in the
future of technology this can be hard to
see sometimes though especially when
cartoons are selling for millions of
dollars and elon is tweeting about dog
money there's a ton of noise in the
crypto space as well as plenty of scams
so be careful out there and quickly i'll
never ask you to message a random phone
number in the comments but you can
subscribe to the channel now once we
separate out all the junk and get to the
core of the technology we need to ask
how can crypto actually help build the
metaverse well the first area is
interoperability right now that
basically just means bringing a digital
asset from one game into another which
might seem silly but remember the
virtual economy already generates over
50 billion dollars per year and that's
without any crypto but honestly who
cares if you can bring a minecraft skin
into call of duty does that really
create any meaningful value or advanced
technology even the slightest bit as
silly as all this sounds i actually do
think it's an important step forward
here's why right now every traditional
tech company is building its own little
walled garden epic games makes fortnite
you buy a skin in fortnite it lives in
fortnite forever now epic games could
allow digital assets from other games to
transfer into fortnite they might need
to build a complex pipeline to transfer
the assets over or define an open
standard but they could do it the only
reason that they don't is because it
would hurt their business epic wants to
be the only company that can sell
dancing bananas in fortnite but if
crypto can break down these wild gardens
the playing field will get a lot more
competitive creators building any small
piece of the metaverse will be able to
ensure that what they build continues to
make them money forever if you can
accept the fact that the 50 billion
virtual economy is basically real at
this point it becomes a lot clearer why
crypto might prove useful here a virtual
asset might be bought in one game and
then sold in another making sure the
creator gets a small royalty payment
would be incredibly complex without
crypto but nfts make this both simple
and reliable this allows developers and
creators to stop worrying about building
an entirely new walled garden and
instead focus on just making useful
building blocks one person builds some
virtual land then another develop some
virtual houses and yes then someone
probably makes a dancing banana actually
the dancing banana probably comes first
let's be honest now to be clear we are
still years from all of this coming
together into anything resembling the
metaverse that zuck is talking about
most of these projects are still in
their infancy and only a few have built
significant user bases but the building
blocks are starting to form the immense
wealth created by the crypto boom over
the past decade really can't be
discounted here bitcoin alone has minted
dozens of new billionaires and most of
those folks aren't about to put their
newfound wealth in traditional tech
stocks they're investing in the next
generation of crypto projects and
helping build infrastructure for what
they see as the future of the internet
obviously zuckerberg isn't the only
person the crypto crowd is up against
though tons of people passionately hate
crypto and want nfts to fail but most of
their criticisms are pretty flawed
you'll commonly hear people say that
nfts are bad because of their
environmental impact but there are
already alternative blockchains that use
less energy per transaction than a
single google search you'll also hear
people point out that nfts are just
links to files stored on centralized
servers and that's true for many
projects but not all some projects do in
fact store all of the data related to
the nft on the blockchain but technical
arguments aside by far the biggest
critique you'll hear is around prices
the anti-crypto crowd will jump at the
opportunity to point out that we're in a
bubble and prices can't possibly stay
this hot just look at what happened
during the dot-com boom and bust and
that's actually a good point we should
look at what happened during the dot-com
boom because i actually think history
could tell us a lot about what the
future has in store here no one denies
that the year 2000 was a crazy time for
technology investing companies were
burning millions of dollars and going
public all while providing very little
real value to everyday people there was
a vague idea that this technology might
be useful one day but few of the
business models made any real sense then
the market crashed people lost stock
portfolios lots of people lost their
jobs but there was a silver lining to
all this market mayhem during the
dot-com bubble investors had financed
huge infrastructure projects focused on
laying fiber optic cable in the ground
actually connecting every computer to
the internet was an incredibly costly
endeavor but without those connections
there would be no internet industry so
the investors ponied up millions of
dollars and got the fiber into the
ground after the dot-com crash it looked
like a waste all those high-flying tech
companies that were planning on using
this new fiber were now bankrupt so were
these cables now useless well not quite
with the infrastructure now available
people started building again and pretty
quickly on october 9th 2002 the nasdaq
hit a new low down 78 percent from its
peak just over one year later a young
mark zuckerberg would hit publish on the
first version of the facebook.com so how
does this all relate to crypto well even
if we are in a bubble it's possible that
the foundational technologies that are
being built today will prove incredibly
useful to a future batch of companies
and it can be useful to go back even
further in time to the turn of the
century the pace of technological
progress was really staggering during
the industrial revolution engineers had
partnered with financiers like never
before and were taking on increasingly
ambitious projects westinghouse and
edison were duking it out to build the
best system for electrification henry
ford was building the first automobile
and the wright brothers were inventing
the airplane the telegraph industry
created a boom of capital and
engineering talent in search of the next
big thing lots of people failed but some
people landed on some absolutely
groundbreaking territory so most crypto
supporters are hoping for something
similar to unfold here the money is
clearly already there and lots of smart
engineers have moved over to building
crypto projects that puts zuckerberg in
a tricky position if one of these
projects breaks out and becomes
essential to the metaverse he could be
stuck fighting on his back foot but in
order to understand exactly how this
might play out we need to dive into the
history of one of the fastest growing
blockchains in the world tons of
metaverse projects are already being
built on top of it so watch this video
to find out why
[Music]